PHILIP GREENSPUN: All right.
So I remembered something
that a physicist told me
about gyroscopic precession,
which I want to share with you.
He said, basically,
angular momentum is always
thought of as a vector.
So if you have, for example,
a helicopter rotor system,
you curl your fingers in the
direction of the rotation.
And then, your
thumb pointing up is
the vector that represents
the angular momentum.
So if, for example, you push up
at the back of the rotor disk,
that's like a turn
in this direction.
So now you have a
vector going this way,
and the new angular momentum is
some kind of sum of those two,
so the sideways vector and the
up vector, maybe a little bit
like this.
And the new rotation of the
disk ends up looking this way.
So that's the
gyroscopic precession.
The new arc looks like
it's been pushed up
from a point 90 degrees
more advanced than the disk.
So if you can remember that--
so I guess, for the
airplane propeller,
let's say we could do-- it's
rotating this way, clockwise.
Rotating this way, so
the vector is going out.
If we push on the side, that's
like rotating this direction,
so it's up.
So the sum is a little
bit up like this
as if it's been pushed
from the bottom.
Be glad you're not a
physics major, I guess,
if you don't like that.
MIT used to require
two years of physics.
Uh-oh.
The clicker is not working.
Oh, maybe it is.
"O ye of little faith."
All right, flight planning--
so let's stick with
the same challenge
that we looked at
before, which is
getting to Bennington, Vermont.
So you have a sectional chart
and you can draw a line.
I did this with SkyVector.
I want to prove to you
that it can be done.
So we basically
say, look, we want
to go from Bedford,
which is here.
We put our ruler on the chart.
It almost goes to
Bennington over here.
Do you see that Moore
state on the chart?
And you can see the
ruler is good for about
88 nautical miles, so it
doesn't quite stretch to the 90,
but it can be done.
And you can also see
this protractor here.
We can get some
idea if we kind of
slide it up and down
the line until we
get a line of longitude.
We can eventually see, OK, it's
a true course of 28 something,
it looks like.
All right.
We'll figure that out
using electronic tools,
but I just wanted to show
you that it can be done.
So the key is, here, you
are making sure that the--
you know, you'll draw
this out with a pencil
and continue the line.
And then, for the
protractor part,
you make sure you put
it on one of these lines
of constant latitude
or longitude,
which gives you an
accurate reference
to true east-west
or true north-south.
So the tools-- as you just saw,
the classical tools for this
are the New York sectional
chart, which I brought,
that plotter, essentially the
ruler and protractor combined,
the E6B calculator which we
played around with a little bit
yesterday.
What's the plan for
our plan though?
We want to make sure that we're
going to find an altitude that
doesn't interfere with
terrain or with which terrain
won't interfere.
We want to make
sure that we're not
going through restricted
airspace that's active.
Or if we are going through a
Class Charlie airspace or Class
Bravo airspace that we're
aware of that in advance
so we can make sure to be
in contact with air traffic
control.
A lot of cross-country
flights, basically all of mine,
I call up air traffic
control anyway
and request VFR advisories.
It's an optional service.
But that way, you're
pretty unlikely to blunder
into airspace that
you shouldn't be in.
We're going to check--
and actually, that reminds
me of something, a comment.
You know, this
ground school stuff,
I think it turns some people
off of flying, per se.
The people who are really
interested in the stick
and rudder stuff, they
say, you know, god,
I don't want to learn
about all that airspace.
I don't want to deal with all
those air traffic controllers.
I just want to fly.
That kind of flying is hard
to do at Hanscom Field, which
is the ninth busiest airport
in the northeast after airports
such as Logan and
LaGuardia and JFK,
but it's very easy to do in a
lot of parts of the country.
You know, if you're out
west, most airports--
you have thousands
of airports in the US
that don't have
control towers, that
don't have any traffic, that are
surrounded by Class G airspace.
You do whatever you want.
So that kind of flying exists.
To get to private, the
FA wants to make sure
that you've at least learned
this stuff so, if you become
that kind of a backwoods
pilot, that you don't blunder
into JFK Class Bravo airspace.
But that kind of fun
flying does exist.
The other thing I
wanted to say is,
in all kinds of
flying education,
there's an emphasis
on the hazardous.
You saw some of that, I
think, yesterday with Mark.
He talked-- you've
got to do this.
You've got to scan for
this because you don't want
to have a midair collision.
Midair collisions
or 1% of accidents
last year according
to the Nall Report.
If you're interested
in these statistics,
the AOPA Safety Foundation
ASF, or Air Safety Institute,
I guess, they have this thing
called a Nall Report, N-A-L-L.
Every year, they analyze all
the kinds of accidents that have
occurred.
But midair collisions
are exceptionally rare,
like I said, 1% of accidents,
maybe 3% of fatal accidents.
So flying tends to
be pretty forgiving.
Usually, most people
who have an accident
have made three
or four mistakes.
It's not like one little mistake
is going to generally get you
into trouble.
So I don't want people
to think that it's
all bureaucracy and
regulations all the time
when you're up in the air,
or that, at any moment,
the airplane could
suddenly stall and spin,
that kind of stuff.
It's just extremely rare.
If you're flying
a Cirrus, you're
nowhere near the stall
in any phase of flight
as long as you're doing things
more or less by the book.
OK.
So anyway, this is our plan, and
we'll follow this kind of step
by step.
OK.
So if we look at
the sectional chart,
we can see that there's these--
see that 41?
That tells you that, if
you're at 4,100 feet,
you have a little bit of
clearance from the terrain,
not enough for flying
on instruments,
but enough for flying visually.
We can also see the
only real airspace
that's on our route is the
Class Bravo airspace itself,
and that goes from 4,000 feet
up to 7,000 feet over top
of Hanscom Field.
So as long as we're in
contact with Hanscom tower
and we're not climbing in
some kind of fighter jet,
we're going to be clear
of Bravo airspace.
And also, if we have
a plane with a GPS VOR
receiver combined
and part of it fails,
you can see there's all these
VORs around here, including
one very close to the
airport that we're going to.
So we're not going to get lost,
even if we can't find Venus
like Captain Sully, can't
talk to air traffic control,
and can't use our GPS, and
can't look out the window.
Actually, a lot of times, we
send soloing students to Keene,
New Hampshire because it's
right next to Mount Monadnock.
And we figure,
well, they probably
can't get lost if there's only
one big mountain sticking up
by itself right
next to the airport.
All right.
It's always good to have a plan.
What if you cross the
mountains and the airport
is hard to find, if the
airport is covered in some fog,
if somebody has driven
a huge lawnmower
onto the middle of the
runway and gotten stuck,
what do we do?
So it's always good
to have a backup plan.
Here's Albany.
Remember I told you that
story about the Cirrus hero.
So he wanted to go here,
to Rensselaer, RPI,
and here's the huge Albany
airport with a wonderful FBO.
It's very inexpensive, cheaper
than Hanscom actually for fuel.
And here's the airport
that he was thinking about.
See it says that it's
a 2,700-foot runway,
but due to the
displaced thresholds,
it's actually shorter.
That doesn't have
a control tower.
That C means it's a common
traffic advisory frequency.
Albany, of course, is a
Class Charlie airport,
so it has all kinds
of great services.
Anyway, so for our alternate,
if things aren't going well,
I want to be drinking
free coffee at the FBO
and borrowing the crew car and
going to a nearby restaurant,
not standing out
there in the wind,
wondering why nobody's at the
Rensselaer County Airport.
OK, so we found an
alternate airport,
not required unless you're IFR,
but always good to think about.
Another reasonable
alternate for Bennington
would be just to make a
U-turn and go back to Hanscom
because it's not
really all that far.
All right.
We can look at the chart
supplement for Bedford
if that's not our home airport.
Remember, this gives all
the information about radio
frequencies and runways.
Similarly for
Bennington, Vermont,
we can see it's a
3,700-foot runway.
Not too much else
that's interesting
here except, if it's
going to be nighttime,
it says the lights won't be on.
We should activate the
medium intensity runway
lights on the CTAF frequency.
So if we click the
microphone five times,
all the airport
lights will come on.
That'll be nice.
Otherwise, not too exciting.
Looks like this runway
is slightly sloped.
That's one thing about Vermont.
See it says 0.9%
slope up, so that's
going to have a slight
effect on our performance.
OK.
So in the old days, we would
just call this 1-800 number
and get our weather briefing.
Or if we were en
route, we might call--
you can see Bridgeport radio
is available here on the VOR.
The VOR for Providence
indicates that, if you
want to talk to Bridgeport
radio, you call them on 122.6,
so we can also talk
to Bridgeport radio.
Although, if we're going
to do a flight plan,
we want to get most of
our stuff done beforehand.
We can look at our AIRMETs.
This is an older slide.
This is not current data,
but at least, at some time,
there was an AIRMET for IFR
and Mountain Obscuration.
So in that case, we might
consider deferring our flight.
There was also AIRMET
Tango for turbulence.
So look at this.
Is it time to freak out?
Well, it says
moderate turbulence.
They used to always say
occasional moderate.
Now they don't put the
occasional in there.
But really, that means there may
be turbulence below 8,000 feet.
Usually, once you get
about through half
of the turbulence
forecast altitude,
it smooths out considerably.
So if it says, as I
mentioned yesterday,
the turbulence forecast goes
up into the flight levels,
it's a pretty ugly day.
If it goes up to
8,000 feet, that's
kind of a standard slightly
windy New England day.
All right.
And you know, you might
get a few bumps climbing up
to 4,000 or 5,000.
METARs-- you get
this list of METARs.
So as I said yesterday, once
you get used to reading these,
this is actually--
I prefer this format.
It's very compact.
You can just zip down.
We can just assume these are
along our route of flight
if we get them in
our briefing format.
So we can see, oh,
it's gusting 19 knots.
It's a gusty day.
When we get to Bennington,
it's 300 at 5 knots,
10 miles broken 7,000.
That's pretty reasonable.
Terminal forecasts-- you
heard about that yesterday.
But again, we get them from the
briefer or the briefing format
along our route of flight.
Remember our goal is to
maintain VFR weather minimums.
Again, you can see how
much more challenging
this is than in a jet.
If you were in a
jet, you would say,
well, I don't need to maintain
VFR because I'll file IFR,
and I don't need to
remain clear of icing
because I can turn on the icing
unless it's incredibly severe.
But you guys will
have this challenge,
at least until you decide that
you want to get your instrument
rating or you want to bring
along a co-pilot who's
instrument rated.
Winds aloft is very
important for this flight
or for this flight
planning task.
We can see Boston.
Albany winds might be the best.
So the winds are coming
from 330, more or less
in our face at 28 knots.
And the temperature
outside is minus 10.
So if it is cloudy, that
means there's a risk of icing.
So in a Piper
Warrior or Cirrus, I
wouldn't do this
trip on this day
unless I thought that
I could remain clear
of the clouds due to that--
you know, if you saw that, at
6,000 feet, it was above zero,
that would be great.
OK, relevant NOTAMs-- the VASI.
See that on the bottom?
The VASI at DDH
is out of service.
So that means we're
not going to have
our visual reference for the
glide slope to the runway.
If it's your home airport,
that's not a big deal.
If it's daytime at an
unfamiliar airport,
that's not a huge deal.
Nighttime at an
unfamiliar airport,
that's kind of a problem.
So you might consider,
at nighttime,
it's better to treat that
like instrument flight.
You might not want to go.
Actually, in my airline days,
we got to this airport at night.
We were really delayed
for a variety of reasons.
But anyway, we get to this
airport in Michigan at night,
and I'm flying left traffic
from the right seat,
so I can't really see
the airport that well,
in this Canadair Regional Jet
which I've just barely learned
to fly, exclusively in the sim.
The first flight in
the real aircraft
was with passengers in the back.
And the runway's
under construction, so
the instrument landing system
which gives you the glide slope
reference, that's out of service
because it would lead you
to a part of the
runway that's closed.
And the VASI and PAPI
that are normally there
at this big airport in
Saginaw or wherever it was,
that's also out of service.
So it's just a pure
visual approach
based on the configuration
of the runway
lights and the geometry
and how it looks,
just like you are flying a
Cessna or a Piper in this jet.
So we got on the
ground, and like I said,
I'm piloting from
the right seat.
I should, perhaps, have just
turned it over to the captain
and said this is a little
beyond my skill level.
But I wanted the
practice, so I did it.
And we turned off the
runway, and nobody
was more surprised
than I when we were
on the ramp, safe and sound.
We got out of the airplane
and this passenger was irate.
He thought somehow
it was my fault.
He saw me having dinner with
a friend at the terminal.
He thought I was the
reason for the delay,
that the flight was held up for
my dinner, and he was enraged.
And I thought to
myself, this guy
has no idea how lucky he is to
be alive with somebody like me
at the controls with no
visual references of any kind,
the first time at
that airport, going--
145 knots was the slowest speed
that we were going at any time.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
So a question on-- just
the one VASI is out, right?
So is there a circumstance,
like if the winds were calm,
you could say, OK, won't land
on 31, I'll land the other way?
PHILIP GREENSPUN:
On the other runway?
You don't want to land
with a tailwind in general,
and there may not be--
we could go back,
but there may not
be a VASI on the other side.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PHILIP GREENSPUN:
Usually, airports
have sort of one runway
that they really love.
Actually, that's interesting.
First of all, they
don't even have a VASI.
They have a PAPI on both sides.
So yeah, actually, that's a
good example of decision making.
If the wind's not too bad--
and actually, at nighttime,
the wind usually quiets down.
So yeah, perfect example
of good decision making.
Just use the other runway.
Why not?
All right.
So we used the plotter.
You saw some of that.
We draw our line.
You can see there we're
referencing the plotter
to true north and we get--
well, this is not for
the Bennington example,
unfortunately.
We get a true course of
038 to some other airport.
Here's what I did
want to show you.
You find some prominent
landmarks along the route.
We talked about that yesterday
in the piloted section,
so things you can
identify from the air.
You get your blank
navigation log form.
You pick an altitude.
So this is one reason
why midair collisions
are exceedingly rare.
If people are above 3,000
feet above the ground,
higher than 3,000
then you get up to your
conventional cruising altitude.
So if you're on
instruments, it's
going to be whole thousands.
So you'll fly on
instruments at 6,000, 8,000,
for example, if you're
on a westbound course.
And you'll fly 5,000, 7,000,
9,000 if you're eastbound.
And then just add
500 if you're VFR.
So airplanes at low
altitudes that are cruising
are almost always
separated by 500 feet.
And therefore,
the conflicts tend
to occur very near airports,
and the conflicts also
tend to occur--
there's one exception
to that rule.
On days when there
is a low cloud
layer like at 3,000
feet, for example,
or 2,500 feet and
everybody who is
VFR is trying to go
under the clouds,
that's when you might
see other airplanes
and have to be vigilant.
But again, you can call
air traffic control
and ask for advisories.
Or now, by January
1 of 2020, everybody
will have a ADS-B so they
have a box in there that's
squawking at you.
Let me tell you that, when
you land at Burning Man,
your fancy traffic
warning system will
get very upset indeed.
We had warnings.
Burning Man has this--
it's not like Oshkosh.
It's super well-organized.
They have people
converging, by design,
from three different
directions to a single point,
flying a pattern that's 500
feet above the runway instead
of the conventional
1,000 or 1,500
for turbine-powered aircraft.
And then you're landing on
a place that's not normally
considered a runway.
So in the Pilatus, we had
the terrain warning system
going nuts because
it didn't know
that there was a runway there.
And we also had the
traffic system going nuts
because we didn't
have ADS-B but we
had enough transponder-equipped
aircraft around us
that it could see them all.
So that was pretty upsetting.
Not as upset as the cool Burning
Man people were to see me,
but my friend had a good time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
what does that mean
if you have [INAUDIBLE],, like
if there could be a situation
but there is none?
PHILIP GREENSPUN: Yeah,
this slide should really
contain that exception,
that it's only up to 3,000
above the--
it's 3,001 feet above
the ground and above.
So the question was, what
if you have low clouds?
How can you do this?
The answer is, if you're
3,000 feet and below,
these conventional cruising
altitudes don't apply.
OK.
Oh, yeah, so this is just
an elaboration of that.
So we're going to be on
a magnetic course that's
generally westbound, so
we'll pick 4,500 feet.
Do we need oxygen
for our flight?
The answer is no.
That's a good thing.
If you are going to be
flying above 10,000 feet
though, if you were
doing a charter flight,
you would need oxygen.
So you might ask
yourself, well, if it's
good for the charter crowd,
why isn't it good for me?
I do think that it--
especially as you
get older, people
tend to get a lot more sharp
if they keep the cabin altitude
5,000 and below or use
supplemental oxygen
in a little airplane.
All right, there's
your chart, 91.211.
You might be asked about that.
All right, let's go back.
So we've got--
I guess, in this flight planning
example, we've done 6,500 feet.
So you can see we
filled in the altitude.
We're going to climb,
go to 6,500 feet.
Our true course is 287, and
you can see these fixes.
They'll be in Fitchburg,
crossing the river,
finding some reservoir,
finally landing at Bennington.
So we'll just see what
the folks-- these slides
were built before Tina and
I took over the course.
All right.
As I said, pick
those winds aloft.
It says reporting points.
Actually, that
should be changed.
That's inaccurate.
They're not winds
aloft reporting points.
These are always forecast.
There's no balloons up there
with sensors to tell you
exactly what the winds are.
OK.
Maybe somebody can remind me
after the class to change that.
OK, so we fill in the forecast
wind, and then we use our--
actually, no.
We're going to need
to find the airspeed,
so we look up the performance
tables for our Piper Warrior
or we pay up for that
Gyronimo app that you saw--
I don't know if they
have a Warrior version,
but maybe they do--
and we pull the
numbers out of there.
I'll just let you digest
this for a moment.
All right.
The important
takeaways from here
are we're going to burn about 2
and 1/2 gallons in the climb, 2
gallons in the
cruise, and you can
see how many minutes it's going
to take to climb and descend.
So that'll just go into our
calculation of the total time.
All right, so we've
got that in there.
See we've got our
true air speeds
for climbing and descending.
What about cruising?
So we use the performance
charts to figure out
that we're going to be going
along here at about 112 knots
before the wind hits us.
We add that to our plan.
We've got all these distances.
We've measured that with
our protractor and ruler
with our plotter.
So we've got the
distances for each leg.
We filled in the
true air speeds.
OK.
Now we do the wind correction.
So remember, if we're reading,
everything is in true.
If we're hearing it
on the ATIS, ASOS,
or from the control
tower, you can just say,
wind check, please.
You don't have to say your
tail number or anything,
and the tower is going
to broadcast back
to you, winds 310 at 12.
OK.
So here's an example.
I can do it in real time
also on the doc camera,
but let me show you this.
So if the wind's
from 210 at 20 knots
and you're trying to go south
at a true air speed at 147--
that's a good Cirrus speed--
you line up 210
to the true index.
And then we're going to draw
a little 20 knot vector here.
It really doesn't
matter where we start.
We're going to draw a
20 knot vector here.
So there's a little
point for 20 knots up.
That represents our wind.
Some people actually
draw it as a vector.
Imagine a little vector here.
Or actually, it'd
be going this way.
Then we rotate so that
we show our true course.
So we're trying to go
south, and the wind
is from this direction,
and we've lined it up.
See how there is 140, 150?
So that's roughly at 147.
So it tells us, with this
little subtraction here,
we're going to be going just
slightly slower than 130
knots or 129 as it
says on the slide,
and we're going to need
to steer about 4 degrees
off the true course.
Does that all makes sense?
It's a little graphical
calculator, basically,
and the idea is you're
starting with a vector that
represents the wind.
You can play around
with this at the break.
And I'll also try using
it on the doc camera
and you'll see just
how much a person can
forget in 17 years or 18 years.
OK.
Now we've filled this in.
We've said, OK, there's
our true air speed.
Here's our wind
correction angle.
Where is our ground speed?
Oh, there's our ground speed.
OK.
So from the ground speed
and the leg distance,
of course, we'll be able
to determine the time.
Now this is the exciting part.
Since we're only
going 90 knots, we
can figure out, for
any given leg length,
how long it's going to take.
So we do that.
Eventually we'll fill it in.
Oh, yeah.
We've got to get the
magnetic variation.
So our true heading is supposed
to be 293 or 283, I guess,
in the cruise, and we add
in the west variation.
Remember east is
least, west is best.
So we've added in that
magnetic variation
and that's the magnetic heading.
If we happen to have--
oh, yeah.
There's a point to this slide.
So what if we take all
that metal fishing gear
and throw it into
the float plane?
That might actually affect
the compass, especially
if you're up in Alaska.
Until about 2001 or
2002, it was required
to carry a gun in your
airplane at all times when
you were flying in Alaska unless
you were in the traffic pattern
at an airport doing flight
training or something.
So if you had your huge rifle up
in the front of your aircraft,
then your compass actually
could be thrown off by the gun
that you were required to carry.
Who knows why you
had to carry a gun?
Why do you have to carry
a gun in your Cessna?
AUDIENCE: Bears.
PHILIP GREENSPUN:
Bears, that's right.
Anyway, they changed the law,
so now you can be a pacifist.
You had to have
ammo too actually.
I think they could
bust you if you
didn't have ammo for your gun.
All right.
Actually, I was going to Alaska
and the regulation was just
being sunset, so I
thought, well maybe
I should bring a gun with me.
So I asked a friend who's
a gun enthusiast, what
would be the right gun?
And he said, oh, you need
this Benelli shotgun,
automatically
reloads the shells,
and you can fire off a whole
bunch of shotgun shells
at once.
It's like, you know,
where can I get one?
And he said, oh, I've
got five, so you can just
borrow one of mine.
OK.
So yeah, here's another
East Coast Aero Club plane.
You've got to
calculate your time.
It might be pretty fast.
That's from Oshkosh.
They brought the B-1.
Actually, this B-1 wasn't--
they ran away from that huge
thunderstorm that I showed you.
So I went through the
thunderstorm in a $99 tent,
and the B-1 left.
And the B-1 taking
off was louder
than anything that happened
during the thunderstorm.
It was crazy loud.
All right, so we've
got it all filled out.
It looks like it's going to
take us a total of one hour.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
I guess about 90
knots about 90 miles,
so yeah, that makes sense.
OK.
We calculate the fuel burn.
So it's going to take us a
minimum of 11 gallons or so
to get there, and we want
to have a half-hour reserve.
I can tell you that's pretty
scary to see the gauges down
that low.
So I think a plan for
a one-hour reserve
is about as low as you
would ever want to plan.
And then beyond that,
we should add some fuel
to get to our
alternate if necessary.
In the instrument
flying world, you
plan to fly to your destination,
fly to your alternate.
Actually, fly to
your destination,
fly in instrument approach,
kind of fly the mist,
fly to the alternate,
and then fly around
for another 45 minutes
to an hour after that.
All right.
What about the VFR
fuel requirements?
So again, the FAA minimums
are pretty scanty,
30 minutes for the
day time, 45 at night.
For helicopters, they're
even less, 20 minutes
and 30 minutes, 20 minutes
day and 30 minutes at night.
OK, weight and balance--
that's off the tail of
a Piper Cub at Oshkosh.
Unfortunately, we don't have
that on the Warriors, which
nobody loves quite as much.
So the glorious plan here--
some of these older
airplanes actually
have better payloads
when they're fully
fueled than the latest and
greatest because they're not
crammed with as much
helpful avionics.
Anyway, so the original
Warrior, this plan
is to take two heavy
people in the front,
400 pounds total, two more
virtuous people in the back,
and 50 pounds of bags.
And you see the max gross
weight is 2,325 on this Piper.
So can we do it?
You're going to have a
long, not to say tedious,
lecture on weight
and balance later,
so we won't belabor this.
But if you look at that loading,
the perspective loading,
I think we should
expect that it's
going to be within the
center of gravity limits
because the heavier
people are in front.
And the real issue is whether
we're overweight or not.
So we are actually overweight.
See that 2,334, and
2,325 is the maximum,
so we're about 10
pounds overweight.
How about, are we out of CG?
We're at about 92 inches.
And you can see here that the
CG envelope goes to about 93.
I guess it goes exactly to 93.
So the CG is fine, but
the weight is too high.
What's the question?
AUDIENCE: Where would you
find all of the information
about the load requirements?
PHILIP GREENSPUN: Oh, yeah,
so that's a good question.
Where do you find all the
information about the weight
and balance that you're going
to use for this calculation.
So remember we
talked about AROW.
You have to have the
airworthiness certificate,
the registration.
The owner's manual, I think, is
the best way to think of the O,
and W is the weight and balance.
So it has to be in the aircraft.
It's usually just in the same
binder as the pilot's operating
handbook or the AFM.
So it's there.
It's specific to the airplane.
And the airplane will get
re-weighed periodically,
and if any kind of
equipment is changed out,
they throw it in there.
But also, these apps--
I mean, the arm of the rear
seats in a Piper Warrior, that
doesn't change from
aircraft to aircraft,
so you just punch that in.
You just punch in, I
think, the total moment
and the total weight
of the empty airplane
into an app like
Gyronimo, and then it'll
calculate the rest
of it for you.
But it already has the arms for
each position in the aircraft.
Remember that's just
a distance from--
they'll pick some arbitrary
point on the aircraft
like just in front
of the propeller,
and you're looking at
the number of inches
back from the
propeller, for example.
That make sense?
OK, so we're overweight.
Will it fly 10
pounds overweight?
What do you guys think?
AUDIENCE: It will.
PHILIP GREENSPUN: It will.
And it will actually
fly up to about 30%
overweight generally, because
I think people get waivers
to take off with
an extra fuel tank
when they're trying to cross
the Atlantic or the Pacific
Ocean or something.
However, it's an
especially bad idea
to go overweight
if it's turbulent
because the aircraft is designed
for handling turbulence up
to its gross weight.
So that's one thing that happens
when people fly over gross,
is that it tends
to strain things
that shouldn't be strained.
So it's a bad practice
as a regular matter.
And of course, you're also
reducing your performance
margins.
But you know, on a winter
day in New England,
you have ample
power, so it's not
like the airplane won't fly.
But it's not legal to
fly, and I try never
to exceed the gross weight.
What was the question?
AUDIENCE: I thought maneuvering
speed goes up with weight.
PHILIP GREENSPUN: It
does go up with weight.
That's a good question.
If maneuvering speed
goes up with weight,
why do you start bending things?
I think that it's not
just G-loads that'll
bend the aircraft.
It's also the overall weight
of the stuff in there.
I don't know.
That's a good question
for a real Course 16
or Course 2 engineer.
What do you guys think?
That's what I've heard though.
If you load it up, it will--
AUDIENCE: There's a max
[INAUDIBLE] weight, right,
which has nothing to
do with air holds?
PHILIP GREENSPUN: That's true.
But I have heard that,
if you're in smooth air,
you'll probably get away with
it for quite a long time.
But also, you want that
performance margin.
If you get into a downdraft
off the lee side of a mountain,
you want some kind of
reasonable climb rate.
And if it's one pound over
gross, you're going to be good.
But the higher you
go over gross weight,
the less performance
margin you have.
That's why training is so great
in a four-seater helicopter
or airplane because you have
a lot of power to get yourself
quickly out of an
uncomfortable situation,
whatever it is, because of those
two empty seats in the back.
All right.
Takeoff performance-- we
figured out that we only
need 1,000 feet of ground roll.
And there are really no
obstacles at Hanscom Field,
so the 2,000 foot number
isn't even relevant.
We have 7,000 feet of
runway so we're good there.
Landing, we're going to clear
a 50-foot obstacle, which
we can expect to find
probably in Vermont.
They have plenty
of trees and hills,
so let's make sure we have
at least 1,500 feet of runway
plus some margin, which we do.
So the book says we can
land in 40% of the runway.
And remember I told you
that, for airline operations,
you try to make sure you
can land in at least 60%
of the runway, so
we're good there.
Here's the sample
flight plan form.
At the bottom, I
say a fun exercise
is to look at the ICAO, the
international flight plan form.
I should have probably
put in another slide.
It's so complicated that there's
nobody on the planet, I think,
that can really fill it out, but
computers will do it for you.
Anyway, here, this has been in
use probably since the '50s.
You're just telling the FAA
what kind of aircraft you have.
A few things-- when they
ask you what type it is,
that would be something like
SR20 for a Cirrus or PA-28
for a Piper Warrior.
True air speed is going
to be as computed,
not indicated but corrected
for your pressure and density
altitude.
Also, on the aircraft
type, there's
a slash for special equipment.
So if you have a GPS on board,
which is no longer special,
you're supposed to put slash
Golf, so SR 20 slash Golf,
so the controllers, if they
are actually talking to you,
they know that they can tell you
to go direct to some fix that's
only in the GPS.
Anybody find the ICAO form?
Who wants to fill it out?
All right, good.
Actually, let's do
it the real way.
Let's go over here to the
doc camera for a moment.
So you've got your
handy dandy pencil,
and let's say the wind
is from the north.
So we just pick
any old spot here.
And let's say it's
a 30 knot wind.
So the wind's blowing from
the north at 30 knots.
That make sense?
OK.
And we want to go south
with a wind true north.
So now we say, well, what's
the air speed of our Cirrus?
It's about 150 knots.
And then we can read at
the bottom of our vector,
and now that wind vector
has blown us to 180 knots.
Is everybody happy with that?
All right.
so We put the dot on the--
and it's explained up here
at the top.
Zoom in slightly.
OK, let's try some
other situations.
What if we want to go west?
That wind from the north, again,
we put it here on the 180.
Oh, sorry, put it on the 150.
So we're cruising at 150.
So remember I said-- this
is actually reflected here--
that a beam wind is a slight
reduction in ground speed
because you're also trying
to fly into the wind.
So you can see here,
our ground speed
has been reduced from
150 to about 148 or 147,
and we need a wind correction.
You can see here this
is the 10 degree line,
so we're going to need a wind
correction of about 12 degrees.
So I'll have to steer
right about 12 degrees.
And let's say the wind
was from the south.
Oh, no, the wind
was from the north.
So if we're trying to go north,
then it becomes really simple.
We put it on 150, and now
we're only going 120 knots.
All right, I think
I survived that.
That was one of my big
fears about this class.
So I learned to do that in--
oh.
I learned to do that in 2001.
In the fall of, I guess,
probably early 2002.
Scary, huh, how
much people forget?
All right.
I just want to show
you one of these sites.
OK, so here we are in SkyVector.
We can store some flight
plans because I am logged in.
So I'll open an
existing plan, and I'll
say I want to go from
Bedford to Bennington today
at 20 Zulu, which is
3 o'clock local time.
So as soon as the class is over,
we teleport to Hanscom Field.
The instructor has already
preflighted the warrior,
so we jump in and we go.
All right.
So here we have--
I think you saw this before.
Here are the points
that I picked out
as being maybe easy to recognize
from the air along our trip.
And we say, OK, well what's
the weather going to be like?
So we just click here, and
we get an official briefing
from a flight service station.
Voila.
Oh, special at Bedford.
Winds 180 at 17, gusting 26,
4 statute miles of visibility,
light rain, mist, overcast
800, temperature's 13,
dew point's 12, so that's not
much of a temperature dew point
split, and sure
enough, the clouds
are pretty close to the ground.
Right?
With a 1-degree split, you'd
expect the clouds to be close.
Peak wind was 180 at 27.
Look at this terminal forecast.
The longer the
terminal forecast,
usually the more
upsetting the weather is.
It's going to be
down to 1 statute
mile, heavy rain plus
RA, overcast 800,
and it's going to be gusting 38.
That's at 1800 Zulu.
I think we're departing
at 20 Zulu, we said,
so that's the forecast
for our departure time.
That's not looking so good.
The good news is there is
no really upsetting NOTAMs.
I think this is this
new-- you can look it up
in the AIM 5/5/5 for the runway
condition code, 100% wet,
but I think that means the
braking action is still
just fine, as you'd expect
for a groove runway.
All right, so
everything's good there.
How about Bennington?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIP GREENSPUN: There's what?
AUDIENCE: There's what
look like [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIP GREENSPUN: Oh.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIP GREENSPUN:
OK, the student
asked about the colored
pins, by which I think
he means the pins of color.
So the red is IFR weather
conditions, and the blue,
I think is, marginal VFR.
And you can set that
up in these layers.
So yeah, see text weather, it's
converting those text weathers
to graphics.
OK.
Good question.
Yeah.
So anyway, it's
kind of an ugly day.
Maybe we want to
fly some other time.
However, we could file the
flight plan if we wanted to.
And it also will give us
this helpful little nav
log here that we can
use in the aircraft.
So all that hard work that
we were doing with the E6B
can be done for us free and very
easily and very conveniently
with just a couple
clicks on SkyVector.
I see that Tina's here, so
she's a huge ForeFlight plan.
Where?
Oh, yeah.
There she is.
So Tina will tell
you, maybe it would've
been even easier on ForeFlight.
But SkyVector does many
fewer things than ForeFlight,
and therefore, the
interface is simpler.
And of course, the ForeFlight
folks will be here at 3:00
and I'm sure they'll
tell you why ForeFlight's
better than SkyVector.
All right.
Let's go back to the
presentation here.
These are just some
of my favorites.
Like I said, there's a
whole ton of these apps.
Question?
AUDIENCE: How do you
file a flight plan?
Are you just printing it out,
or do you send it to someone?
PHILIP GREENSPUN: Oh, yeah.
The question is, what does it
mean to file a flight plan?
So the FAA has these computer
systems, these old mainframes,
I think.
For a while, they had
Philips mainframe computers.
You may not have
heard of Philips
as a popular vendor
of computer systems.
That's because they exited
the business, I think,
in the late '60s or early '70s.
But the FAA had
all this software
that was running in
Philips machine code.
So they were emulating
the Philips mainframes
on more modern systems right
up into the 2000s at least.
I'm not sure if it's
still that old Philips
code that takes your flight
plan, but something similar.
So your flight plan gets sent
from whatever application
you're using, I think,
to maybe Lighthouse,
the Lockheed Martin
spinoff contractor that
took over flight service
in 2005, I believe it was.
And from there, it goes into
some FAA computer system
and it's accessible
to the controllers.
If it's an instrument
flight plan,
they'll develop a route for you.
If it's just a VFR flight
plan, point to point,
and you're going to activate
it and deactivate it manually,
it may stay with the
flight service station
because the controllers
have no reason
to know about that or care.
Does that answer your question?
Yeah, so there's a whole
bunch of different places
that can enter the flight plan.
Where it gets more
complicated and where
I think an application
like ForeFlight
might come in very handy
is international flying.
So if you go to
Mexico or something,
you end up physically walking
over to the control tower
and there's people
who help you there.
They fill out the forms on
paper and it's kind of fun.
You've got to budget
an extra half hour
before every departure to
fill out all the paperwork,
but they're all nice people.
AUDIENCE: So if you had to call
in your flight plane, which
happens more than you would
expect because you could be
out in the wilderness
with no internet,
what information do
you provide then?
PHILIP GREENSPUN: Yeah.
The question is, what if you
have to call in on the radio
your flight plan to the
flight service station?
What do you provide?
Basically, they'll
prompt you if need be,
but some people, on their
kneeboard or whatever,
will have the elements
of a flight plan.
And you just read out the
same as the flight plan form,
where you want to go, what
your registration number
is, 707 Whiskey Tango, your
type, SR20 slash Golf, how
many souls onboard,
how much fuel you have,
all that other stuff.
And they enter it in
the system just as
if you've done it on the phone.
You can also do it by calling
that 1-800-WX-BRIEF number.
You can do everything by phone.
Question?
No.
All right, let's see what
else we've got in here.
Suggested reading--
so FAR 61 and 91
is the stuff that you're
going to be tested on,
but it might not be the
best plan for prudence.
So for example, in Canada,
you need special training
and an endorsement at least.
I think it might be a rating.
You need special
training and, I think,
a rating to fly at night VFR.
In some countries,
VFR flight at night
is just simply unauthorized.
As Tina mentioned, you
have to file IFR, I think,
if you want to go flying
around at night in Mexico.
For FAR 135, they say, look,
you can't fly single pilot
IFR with no autopilot.
You have to have some way of
taking your hands off and not
having the airplane go
upside down in the clouds.
Yeah, so just look at those
operating limitations.
And when you're doing your
flight plan, just ask yourself,
should I be doing something that
is more aggressive than what
the charter and the airline
crews are permitted to do?
All right, so we
can take questions.
And meanwhile, I'll
show you-- while you're
thinking of your questions,
here is the planning.
Well, it doesn't really
show the planning,
I guess some of the planning.
We had to load up this
Pilatus with 60 sea turtles.
I think that was late
November or early December.
So you can see, there they are
in the back of the airplane.
They're in these
Chiquita banana boxes.
Here is a Garmin 650 in the
front of the airplane showing
that we're just entering
Virginia, I believe,
and we still have two
hours to go before we
get to Panama City, Florida.
We're getting 281 knots
over the ground, which
is a little bit of a tailwind.
That's unusual going to Florida.
When we get there, we get
treated like rock stars.
There's a TV station there.
The turtles are here
being transferred,
and there's our
cockpit at night.
We flew back at night.
It was kind of a long
day, maybe 7:00 AM to 9:00
PM or something.
And there's one of our
sea turtle friends.